what looks like a simple garage here
turns out to be a sophisticated energy
storage unit made in Germany engineers
from the state of Brandenburg developed
the electrolysis device for generating
hydrogen the high-tech system has
already attracted Chinese investors
they're set to pay 6.4 million euros for
a unit nearly 10 times bigger than this
one opens in hebei province there's a
strong surplus of wind energy that can't
be stored in the electricity grid this
electrolysis unit allows us to
temporarily store the surplus in the
form of hydrogen it can then be used to
fuel electric vehicles or to synthesize
methane which can then be burned for
electricity or heat so far hydrogen
technology has taken something of a
backseat in Europe of all places it
could turn out to be China that could
take a leading role in this green
technology although it is the world's
largest emitter of co2 and a major air
polluter China has taken some time to
realize it have to do something about
its massive emission problem that's why
they're betting on this green technology
now but we don't need to be worried that
Germany could lose pace with the Chinese
I think the fact that german-built
electrolyzers going to China and the
bilateral cooperation in automotive
engineering shows that there is a great
opportunity for German industry and an
opportunity for small companies like
McPhee near Berlin its engineers develop
the hydrogen production and storage unit
which is currently built by an Italian
branch the company is hoping for follow
up orders since McPhee's advanced
technology could provide a way of
reducing China's air pollution and help
the country enter the clean energy
business
and you know fix this boo-boos Stein
there's a growing awareness of green
technology in China
and they know that sustainable energy
offers a lot of market potential so the
Chinese want a piece of the pie economic
giant China is taking its first steps
towards an energy turnaround and the
fact that Germany is providing the
resources could also spur interest in
hydrogen technology in Europe